[Musique]
on débat sur france 24 il a mis sa
casquette de chef des armées en pleine
campagne du second tour des législatives
lors de son voyage en roumanie en
moldavie et badel vaqueront a rendu
visite aux forces françaises sur la base
de l'otan près de constanta au sud est
de la roumanie le chef de l'état a
soutenu les président roumain et
moldaves face à l'invasion russe en
ukraine emmanuel macron a aussi suggéré
à volodimir zelensky de négocier à un
moment la fin de la guerre avec la
russie alors que kiev vous le savez
demande de son côté des armes
supplémentaires à l'occident le
président français a souhaité que
l'union européenne puisse envoyer un
signal clair et positif à la moldavie la
moldavie candidate à l'adhésion lors du
prochain sommet européen
alors que peut-on retenir de cette
séquence internationale européenne de
l'est qui emmanuel macron et comment
finalement s articulent tel avec la
séquence politique des législatives une
fenêtre de négociations existe-t-elle
entre la russie et l'ukraine quelle
architecture de sécurité le président
français propose t'il face à la russie
emmanuel macron la diplomatie d'ue en
même temps le chef de l'état français en
roumanie en moldavie on en débat avec
mes invités j'ai plaisir d'avoir à mes
côtés marie dumoulin bonsoir ancien
diplomate directrice du programme europe
élargie au sein du conseil européen des
relations étrangères merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous et bienvenue à vous en
face de vous alberto toscano bonsoir ce
journaliste et voilà c'est la
journaliste écrivain italien votre
dernier livre alberto ti amo francia de
léonard de vinci à pierre cardin ces
italiens qui ont fait la france est une
réédition bienvenue dans le débat avec
nous également nicolas tenzer bonsoir
soit en fait soeur à sciences po
directeur du site desk russie nous
attendons elle va arriver d'un moment à
l'autre oksana mitrofanova qui est
docteur en sciences politiques et
chercheuse à l'institut de l'histoire
mondiale de l'académie nationale des
sciences d'ukraine à kiev vous pouvez
tous réagir sur les réseaux sociaux
justement en vous mettant sur le hashtag
débat f24
deux jours aux portes de l'europe le
chef de l'état a donc voulu soutenir la
présence française
romagné en particulier il s'est engagé
auprès des ukrainiens mais en même temps
il évoque la nécessité de négocier on
écoute emmanuel macron nous voulons
bâtir la paix ce qui veut dire qu'à un
moment nous souhaitons tous que le feu
cesse et que les discussions reprennent
parce qu'à un moment donné quand nous
aurons aider au maximum à résister quand
je le souhaite letren aura gagné surtout
que le feu pourra cesser nous devrons
négocier
[Musique]
président ukrainien ses dirigeants devra
négocier avec la russie
c'était lors de son séjour en ukraine
marie dumoulin on se souvient de ce
qu'avait dit emmanuel macron qui a fait
bondir les ukrainiens il ne faut pas
humilier la lumière poutine est ce qu'il
est vraiment dans cette diplomatie du un
même temps
il faut pas humilier la russie vladimir
poutine est ce qu on est dans du en même
temps
on est dans une approche qui consiste à
dire qu'il faut considérer la situation
immédiate et donc soutenir l'ukraine
notamment lui fournissant de
l'assistance humanitaire et de
l'assistance militaire mais qu'il faut
aussi considérer le long terme et que à
long terme à un moment il faudra être
capable de ré engager une discussion
avec la russie qui n'utilisent pas
vraiment le terme long terme si c'est un
peu la vie grille de s'élancer
l'ambiguïté de ces déclarations et le
ter l'emploi du terme humiliés et est
particulièrement malvenu dans le cas
d'un pays qui est en train d'agresser
son voisin il était d'autant plus
malvenue qu'il renvoyait au discours que
les russes eux-mêmes tiennent sur la
politique des occidentaux à leur égard
dans les années 90 donc c'est un terme
qui est pas innocent et c'est pour ça
qu'il a fait très fortement réagir les
ukrainiens et un certain nombre de
partenaires européens mais je crois que
la logique de dire il n'y aura de
sécurité européenne qu'en tenant compte
de la place de la russie sur le
continent et de ce qu'elle représente y
compris lorsqu'elle représente une
menace cette logique là on peut la
comprendre nicolas tenzer vous la
comprenez cette logique écoutez moi je
même temps je pense que j'ai d'abord je
la comprends pas enfin d'abord le
discours d' humiliations va pas y
revenir effectivement c'était une bourde
majeure qu'elle faisait l'affairé on l'a
très justement je veux dire il faisait
référence à c'est un discours de la
propagande du kremlin pour pas l'oublier
l'humiliation pardon l'humiliation oui
l'humiliation enfin voilà et donc
c'était pas à droit de le faire surtout
que c'était connu et je dirai tout le
monde le sait je dirais que ça les
parties encore une fois c'est dans tous
les manuels si j'ose dire du petit
kremlinologues bien connu deuxièmement
sur la question je dirais de la
négociation veut dire ce n'est pas
l'urgence aujourd'hui l'urgence et que
vous avez à peu près cent mille
l'ukrainien qui sont morts vous avez
toutes les familles chrétiennes qui sont
éprouvés qui connaissent qui ont un
proche un fils un frère une épouse marie
une mère un père qui sont morts qui ont
tous des proches qui sont morts le sujet
aujourd'hui c'est de donner les armes le
plus rapidement possible pour gagner la
guerre ce n'est pas d'imaginer le futur
je dire aujourd'hui il ya quand même une
urgence et tout est fait
encore une fois tout est fait qui parle
du futur comme ça c'est de la
distraction et sur l'infraction ces deux
là disent travailler sur le fond je
termine juste rapidement sur le fond sur
le fond encore une fois avec la russie
il faudra certainement discuter donc
vous dites pas avec le real de discuter
discuter ce n'est pas négocier et
discuté avec la russie ce n'est pas
discuté avec le criminel contre
l'humanité qu'est monsieur poutine et là
dessus je crois que là aussi la
distinction est très claire il faut
effectivement bien distinguer le peuple
russe la russie qui restera de ce régime
criminel qu'il faut effectivement non
seulement humilié mais tout simplement
vaincre à plate couture en conséquence
il est l'heure avec la russie que si les
meilleures poutines est destitué en tout
cas s'il n'est plus voilà c'est bien de
pouvoir le plus vite possible mais
évidemment on peut agir dans ce sens
qu'un orage un partage absolument pas ce
discours qui veut la guerre je pense que
le problème est justement de sortir
cette guerre n est pas de gagner la
guerre se guérit personnes à gagner
c'est de cette guerre
personne n'a gagnera sur le plan
militaire et je pense qu emmanuel macron
a eu parfaitement raison à dire qu'il
faut pas humide et la russie parce que
le but est de bâtir de nouvelles à ce
nouveau système de sécurité en europe et
pas d'humilier un pays la russie la
russie a tort poutine à tort et
l'agresseur sans le sait on l'a dit tout
le temps mais les problèmes
pas de ceux d alimenter la guerre les
problèmes de bâtir la paix ces magasins
makro et avec mario draghi avec un
choses sont en europe ce qui essaie de
favoriser un dialogue qui est le système
les etats-unis ont fait la guerre du
vietnam ont réalisé des bombardements
épouvantable ils ont utilisé des armes
chimiques et à l'époque nous on disait
même s'ils ont critiqué les états unis
il faut pas humilier les stein
c'est pas par une humiliation d'une
puissance qu on arrivera à bâtir donc la
position des belle macro et la bonne
alors dont la vision est tendre et
celle d'ailleurs parfaitement le mari du
moulin est ce que les ukrainiens sont
prêts parce que c'est même à négocier je
crois qu'à ce stade il est beaucoup trop
tôt pour parler de négociation parce
qu'en réalité ni les russes ni les
ukrainiens y sont prêts les deux parties
donc sur quoi parle-t-il de négociations
aujourd'hui sinon nil aucune des deux
parties n'est prête à le faire parce que
il viendra un moment et c'est d'ailleurs
ce qu'il dit ou ces négociations seront
possibles et nécessaires on n'est
clairement pas à ce moment là et dans le
fait d'armes et l'ukraine et de le faire
vite il y a aussi une nécessité qui est
de rééquilibrer le rapport de force sur
le terrain et d'éviter que lorsque ce
moment viendra où la négociation sera
possible cette négociation ne se fasse
entièrement au terme de la russie parce
que l'ukraine ne sera plus en situation
de deux de discuter en réalité elle sera
obligée de capituler donc
pour moi il faut vraiment distinguer ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui qui consiste à
rééquilibrer l'équation sur le terrain
de ce qui devra se passer plus tard
lorsque les deux parties seront prêtes à
une négociation il faut préserver la
possibilité que cette négociation ait
lieu à ce moment là donc il faut
conserver la possibilité de pouvoir
parler à la russie quelles que soient
ses autorités nicolas kenzari
l'ukrainien me demande de plus
d'armements lance de l'armement lourd
c'est encore le cas aujourd'hui donc
effectivement ils n'ont ne sont pas
prêts à la discussion donc encore une
fois je dirais il faut parler de choses
très concrètes le vrai sujet ce sur quoi
pourrait porter une éventuelle
négociation
encore une fois il ya une chose qui est
impossible si l'on est sérieux à dire
tous les dirigeants y compris le
président de la république ont dit nous
tenons à l'intégrité territoriale et la
souveraineté de l'ukraine c'est une
position a tenu d'ailleurs avant le 24
février le début de la nouvelle
offensive russe si nous sommes logique
ça veut dire que nous considérons que
nous devons aider l'ukraine à
l'accomplir c'est à dire à récupérer les
territoires perdus en 2014 et je crois
aussi
l'intégrité territoriale de l'ukraine
c'est ça c'est à dire que les
territoires qui appartiennent à
l'ukraine le dôme basse et la crimée
concrètement et bien se sont ils sont
d'ukrainiens d'après la loi est encore
une fois en accord avec toutes les
déclarations des chefs d'état
gouvernements de tous les pays de
l'union européenne plus des états unis
c'est la raison pour laquelle ils
craignent ne veulent pas voilà et donc
ça veut dire aussi que ce qui est
attendu du président de la république
s'il se rend effectivement en ukraine
c'est de dire voilà je précise que j'ai
dis parce qu'il a encore redit récemment
c'est ça que ça signifie et sur cette
base là nous nous tenons aux côtés de
l'ukraine n'est pas nous nous tenons aux
côtés de lavalade de la résine nous
demandons à l'ukraine non nous demandons
nous tenons à les gars à côté de
l'ukraine nous demandons à la russie
dans ce cas là une fois que ce sera
réalisé dans quelques fois que les turcs
russes seront retirés du donbass
pourrait brûler revoilà et nous devons
aider l'ukraine à objat voilà une fois
que c'est terminé cela est fait
évidemment on est on est sûr monsieur
faire
moi je crois qu'il faut bâtir la paix et
je cours je vous signale que dans
l'union européenne
il y a un bep chypre dont le territoire
est occupé depuis juillet 74 car un pays
de l'otan la turquie la cie démocratique
turquie et et personne ne dit rien dont
il ya des états de fait en diplomatie et
un politique qui se bâtissent au fur et
à mesure que les zones est et décennies
passent donc là vous voulez boire je
prenais la négociation alberto toscano
je pose un problème de négociation et de
réalisme et de bon sens et de bâtir la
paix plutôt que deux essayer de gagner
une guerre qui de toute façon ne sera
gagné pendant lequel prix injure à quel
prix ont bâti cette paix parce que vous
êtes l'exemple de chypre est ce que ça
veut dire ou bien eu la maîtrise dont
basse ou non il ya eu les accords de
minsk le président m'a cran pendant son
premier voyage à moscou et ensuite à
kiev a dit il faut que les deux parties
respectent les accords de misc c'est à
dire que même des côtes et ukrainienne
il n'ya eu de points de vue français des
choses qu'on aurait pu faire un plus
pour les respecter dont il ya problème
d'autonomie nous avons fait une guerre
amoureuse de la vie au kosovo nous
affirmer les droits du kosovo avoir
l'indépendance à un problème d'autonomie
existe dans tout l'est européen j'étais
pendant deux ans envoyé spécial as you
go story je connais je crois c'est bien
la mosaïque ils relèvent qu'elles le
seraient en tirer dans les réseaux
l'espère d autonomie et surtout partir
d'une volonté de paix pas plutôt que
d'une volonté de guerre et de violence
miss brésil savoir et c'est tout à fait
inexact de dire qu'il ya l'autonomie
dont les accords de minsk encore une
fois c'est la forme de décentralisation
ensuite encore une fois tout le monde le
sait ce qu'ils n'ont pas respecté les
accords de minsk 2 ce sont les russes
d'ailleurs ça a été clairement dit par
les autorités françaises aussi je veux
dire allez je te dis voulais je dis que
tous les deux auraient dû faire plus les
dix mois du scrutin précédent évidence
aux accords de minsk de toute façon on
n'en est plus là puisque le 21 février
en reconnaissant l'indépendance
des deux entités autoproclamées de
donetsk et de lougansk les russes ont de
fait mis à la poubelle les accords de
minsk donc les accords de minsk il
n'existe plus aujourd'hui on n'en est
plus là il on en est à essayer de faire
en sorte que les russes gagnent le moins
de terrain possible pour que l'état de
fait que vous décriviez porte sur une
portion la plus limitée possible du vert
le jaune peut donc ça veut dire marée
des mollahs que ces accords de minsk
sont caduques qui ne pourraient plus
constituer une base de négociations
entre les deux pays puisqu'on parle de
négociations de fait il n'existe de fait
les accords de minsk c'était des accords
par lesquels la russie s'engager
explicitement parce que les deux régions
reviennent danse ou sous le contrôle de
l'ukraine et sous la souveraineté
ukrainienne aujourd'hui les russes ne
tient pas ce discours là oksana
mitrofanova nous a rejoint bonsoir mai
si d'être avec nos docteurs en sciences
politiques chercheuse senior à
l'institut d'histoire mondial de
l'académie nationale des sciences
d'ukraine à kiev vous êtes donc bien sûr
ukrainienne est ce que vous souhaitez
qu'emmanuel macro aille à kiev bonsoir à
tout le monde tout d'abord oui bien sûr
il faut dire qu'ils en attendent en
ukraine le manuel macron avec
l'impatience est depuis des années il ya
déjà deux ans trois ans ont depuis des
années vous dites moi depuis le début de
la guerre j'attends je veux préciser ça
qui est déjà avant la guerre on a
vraiment entendu avec l'impatient
l'évier la visite des manuels macro et
pourquoi vous voulez qu'ils aillent à
kiev vraiment pour plusieurs raisons
parce que je suivais les relations de
femmes que craignaient depuis 20 ans je
peux constater qu'elle visite par
exemple du président jacques chirac a
menés vers beaucoup beaucoup de projets
parce que si par exemple il n'ya pas de
guerre souvent le président arrive avec
l'équipe donc avec l'équipe et on peut
dire que ça
mais la région de coopération dont
beaucoup de demain donc du coup oui bien
sûr on entendu emmanuel macron et
surtout dans le temps dans le tarn de
guerre le visite du président de la
france puis quand même et européens du
nucléaire c'est très importante mais
c'est le soutien du peuple c'est le
soutien de beaucoup moins saignant c'est
aussi le dialogue avec the links qui
dialogue bilatéral qui était occupé par
compréhension entre les deux pays entre
deux pays et quand il appelle justement
à discuter avec la russie à ce que
l'ukraine et la russie discute qu'est ce
que vous répondez et lorsqu'on entend
effectivement aux élèves qui dira il
nous faut plus d'armes 1 qu'est ce que
vous dites de ce que dit emmanuel macron
quand il appelle au dialogue avec la
russie 1 s'il s'agit des dialogues avec
la russie à l'étape actuelle bien sûr
zelensky il a dit qu'il peut a parlé
avec poutine parce que c'est que de
petits ne se répandent la fin de la
guerre mais elle peut parler de ce fait
parce que l'essentiel c'est la fin de la
guerre comme en temps de mener
négociations dans la citation quand il
ya les bombardements donc vous pensez
que la à ce stade vous le dit mr aulas
qui accepterait un cessez le feu enfin
en tout cas négocierait cessez le feu
avec mais cela dépende de conditions
bien sûr mais ça de passer à dépendre
des conditions d'abord
lens qui est bien conscient que dans un
aussi tout dépend de poutine donc la
seule personne qui peut donner l'ordre
finir la guerre c'est bien sûr je suis
présidente de l'are aussi mais les
conditions c'est très important bien sûr
le cra n est pas prêt du tout par ni
territoire n'y ait d'autres choses ça
dépend de sa dépendent des prix on ne
peut dire aussi intéressant justement de
voir que que madame mitrofanova attend
comme beaucoup d'ukrainiens d'ailleurs
la visite d' emmanuel macron on voit
effectivement que dialogue qui l'a
maintenu avec vladimir poutine et macro
n'a finalement pas vraiment aboutie est
ce qu'on peut dire c'est un échec alors
d'abord il faut dire qu'il y est déjà
allé en février il s'était rendu à
moscou puis à kiev est donc là c'est sa
deuxième visite d'après tiendra leur vie
contre avant il n'était pas allé il
n'était pas allé enfin aucun président
français s'était rendu en ukraine depuis
plus de 15 ans qui expliquait aussi le
l'impatience à recevoir sa visite
est ce que ces contacts avec l'admirent
cantine sont un échec tout dépend en
fait de l'objectif qu'on considère si on
espérait que ses contacts suffirait à
changer la position de la russie oui
c'est un échec si on considère qu'il
faut pouvoir maintenir un canal de
discussion ne serait ce que pour pouvoir
sonder l'état d'esprit de la dit mi-août
in et lui dire ce qu'on a à lui dire
parce que sinon personne d'autre ne le
lui dira mais s'ils n'écoutent pas
ça dépend pas de nous ce qui dépend de
nous c'est de lui parler et ça vous
pensez je pense que ça reste important
mais je suis une ancienne diplomate donc
je vois là donc ça fait partie de ce
qu'on appelle c'est ce qu'on appelle la
diplomation ça fait partie de la
diplomatie et a fortiori dans un régime
où effectivement tout dépend du chef de
l'état c'est à lui qu'il faut parler si
on veut passer des messages nicolas
tenzer mais je pense qu'effectivement
garder un canal de discussion ouvert en
soi n'est pas une mauvaise chose
personne d'ailleurs je vois personne ne
la critique est donc vous ne c'est un
échec mais encore une fois je pense
qu'il faut bien préciser trois heures
lia discussion oui faut toujours parler
vaut mieux parler bien sûr
dire que c'est je reviendrai sur des
chèques que c'est un dialogue n'ont
certainement pas de dialogue parce qu'il
faudrait qu'il y ait quelqu'un une
réciprocité un argumentaire et encore
une fois je leur précise négociations
sûrement pas et je pense qu'il est
extrêmement dangereux et en tout cas
perturbateur pour tous nos alliés
européens là je reviens d'une série de
déplacements successifs au cours des
trois dernières semaines en estonie à
bratislava donc en slovaquie et en
pologne et je m'aperçois encore une fois
en voyant tous les dirigeants y compris
certains présidents premiers ministres
ministres intellectuelle parlementaire
de ces pays kylie a aujourd'hui une
vraie suspicion que derrière ces
discussions les scènes perception alors
encore une fois on peut dire qu'elle est
fausse qaîda erronée mais qui a une
perception que derrière emmanuel macron
est prêt à faire des concessions sur le
dos de l'ukraine et je pense que dans sa
visite actifs il sera essentiel
effectivement que le président de la
république dise clairement il n'est pas
question de céder sur l'intégrité
territoriale qu'il re précise bien tout
cela sur l'échec très rapidement je
reprends uniquement les propos de
florence parly lorsqu'elle était
ministre des armées a en juillet 2020
elle a dit pour l'instant toutes les qui
était engagé après notamment la
rencontre de brégançon 2019 n'a rien
donné et c'est un constat je pense
brutale sec et claire et quand on voit
ce qui s'est passé avec la guerre
d'extermination qui a mené la russie
depuis on s'aperçoit encore plus que
c'est un échec et que il aurait mieux
fallu certainement prendre des mesures
plus tôt de rétorsion à l'égard de la
russie de poutine bien qu'ils font tout
de même avec les sanctions oui mais
beaucoup trop tard encore une fois nous
étions allés depuis dix ans attendez je
termine si vous permettez depuis plus de
dix ans dira si nous avions encore une
fois était beaucoup plus sévère en
raison des crimes de guerre et contre
l'humanité massif en syrie après
l'invasion de la géorgie 20% du
territoire seront pas occupés après
l'attaqué contre l'ukraine en 2014 nous
serions peut-être pas là aujourd'hui je
voudrais renseigné monsieur qu'est
l'europe vers cette même membre il n'y a
pas que la pologne et l'estonie
dont il y à l'espagne l'italie
l'allemagne qui ont qui soutiennent la
proposition de manuel micro et
d'ailleurs avant cette crise nous
européenne et européiste on critiquait
beaucoup le gouvernement polonais et
aujourd'hui on ne touche derrière le
gouvernement polonais dont geico au
monde connaît parfaitement les côtés et
on se dit qu un don l'europe dans son
ensemble
mais entendre avec la russie elle me
comprend bien sûr bien sûr
en même temps il y aura un impact n'est
pas le sujet de ce nom
et c'est heureusement qu'il n'ya pas
qu'à l'épaule et qui est qui qui qui
font la politique européenne
heureusement que la politique européenne
et fait plus à paris que varsovie mais
ceci dit nous avons fait l'essentiel ou
est-ce qu'on veut aller nous nous on
paie sa censure nous l'économie
européenne pc sanctions plus que la
russie les actions si dur qu'on a fait
affaiblissent plus notre économie que
l'économie russe on est dans la
situation où cessez lé feu qu'est ce que
ça veut dire cessez le feu cessez le feu
ça veut dire d'arrêter de tirer de se
tirer dessus dans le reste sur les
positions ou non évidemment six
choristes ce qu'est le discours
lancerait discours du bon sens de la
peine et c'est celui tout y passe c'est
les résultats du pape selon lui ce tour
de m'accrocher nous détenons sait pas
dire non dans ma chronique du pape et à
partir de là et il ya un besoin de
référents que vous n'avez pas entendu et
de toute façon que vous n'avez pas
besoin d'un compris oksana mitrofanova
c'est votre discours à des conditions 1
je voudrais te donner la position nos
clients tout simplement on peut parler
des tactiques d'emmanuel macron des
conversations téléphoniques bon on va
les définir ce contact au début éthiques
voilà bon tactique des manuels mac on
sait mener des conversations
téléphoniques avec poutine donc au début
bien sûr les ukrainiens on entendait en
plus ou parce que c'était le plus
important de se voir le résultat mais on
ne voit très clair et net que les mois
passent il n'a pas du tout des résultats
donc ou pas de vue de l'ukraine c'est
diallo que les conversations
téléphoniques pour nous c'est un
monologue ça donne l'impression que
manuel makoun il pas mais il n'a pas du
tout des résultats de son interlocuteur
donc moi je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec mon collègue nicolas tenzer pour le
dialogue il faut le dos c'est le mot
dialogue mais malheureusement assez
transforme en monologue 100 euros on
refuse de cesser le feu donc reçu
réfugiés l'idée de rechercher le feu ça
ne parle pas de manuels makonda leur as
marsa ne parle pas des manuels ma
conscience et qu'on arrête de se tirer
dessus et on reste sur la position ou
émet depuis 2001 qui ont fait des
guerres et plus non mais attendez c'est
la grèce l'agresseur c'est la russie il
faut quand même pas mélanger je veux
dire autant ça c'est fait je ne sais pas
la bouche mais qu'est ce que ça veut
dire en tout cas on a bien
voilà c'est le débat justement pour pour
pour terminer cette question-là oksana
mitrofanova aujourd'hui ce que souhaite
kiev c'est plus d'armements de
l'armement lourd dont ne parle pas de
tentatives où est-ce qu'on en parle de
tentative de négociation aussi parce que
pour l'instant on voit surtout qu'ils
demandent des sommes supplémentaires
vous avez parfaitement raison de ses
besoins le craignent maintenant à
l'étape actuelle c'est bien sûr
l'allemand l'armement et l'armement
lourd et je voudrais utiliser cette
citation pour remercier la france pour
command césar vous voilà je serais
désolé revenir là dessus
il est allé voir donc les militaires
français sur la base de l'otan en
roumanie il les a confortés
effectivement cette livraison des canons
caesar peut-être d'autres viendraient en
tout cas il est quand même allé en tant
que chef de guerre il a montré qu'il
s'engageait pour l'ukraine est ce que
c'est un peu le sentiment vous avez eu
sur cette visite
vraiment on entend beaucoup bec et la
france va augmenter l'aide militaire et
le crâne parce que il faut souligner qu
au début ça pue la position de la france
était pas clair du tout contre les
autres pays déjà de l'ukraine avant la
guerre par exemple les états unis et la
grande bretagne pologne il faut
connaître qu'avant la guerre là on était
déjà envoyé moi j'ai reçu les questions
des militaires ukrainien des ministères
de défense pourquoi la france ne pas
aider à le craindre je souligne après la
guerre je ne savais pas qu'il raconte
mais bien sûr la position petit à petit
s'est échangé il faut parler des anti
char mais par exemple milandes c'est
important surtout les canons caesar qui
sont très efficaces qui sont déjà en
activité sur le front et bien sûr on
espère que la france va augmenter l'aide
exactement militaire c'est la première
demande de l'udc tôt mardi mme mouleres
est effectivement sk une position de
emmanuel macron qui a changé un petit
peu tout en voulant garder ce en même
temps qu'on décrivait en début
d'émission il ya une guerre qui a
commencé et la france avant le début de
cette guerre disait on soutient
l'intégrité territoriale et la
souveraineté de l'ukraine après le début
de cette guerre soutenir l'intégrité
territoriale et la souveraineté de
l'ukraine ça veut dire lui donner les
moyens de défendre cette intégrité
territoriale c'est pour revenir sur la
question du cessez le feu le problème
c'est qu'en réalité à ce stade les
russes ne sont pas prêts au cessez le
feu et ils ont redoublé au contraire
leurs rôles et leurs frappes
d'artillerie lourde dans le nom basse
donc le renforcement de l'aide militaire
au cren il vise aussi à
mettre un coup d'arrêt à cette antenne 2
photos marrantes un maximum de
territoires dans le dos masse je suis
tout à fait d'accord les russes ils
refusent ce feu je suis je dit il
faudrait un cessez le feu c'est arrêter
de se tirer dessus ceux qui tirent sur
les agresseurs et les russes mais sur ce
fait n'y a pas de doute mais en tout cas
il pourrait y avoir une médiation
européenne vous pensez
nicolas tenzer avec justement emmanuel
macron mario draghi le chef du
gouvernement italien ont à l'aide olaf
scholz aussi peut-être encore une fois
je pense que ça va un moment emmanuel
macron dans un entretien avec la presse
régionale avait dit la france a une
position de conciliatrice ou de
médiateur ça a été extrêmement mal reçue
raison me semble-t-il du côté ukrainien
qui ont dit aujourd'hui on n'a pas
besoin de médiateur on a besoin d'alliés
c'était sur itélé propos des officiels
d'ukrainiens en sept ans exactement et
aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui encore une
fois on n'a pas besoin de médiateur et
je pose surtout que si un médiateur qui
est l'union européenne se seront pas
uniquement des pays qui à tort ou à
raison on l'a aussi le faisons pas de
procès d'intention mais
l'allemagne l'italie et la france sont
suspectés encore une fois à voyons les
réactions dans l'europe du nord dans
l'europe centrale y compris d'ailleurs
en espagne et au portugal qui sont
suspectés d'être les plus tièdes et donc
encore une fois je je vois pas du tout
qu'il puisse y avoir une médiation et
encore une fois sur quoi encore une fois
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui l'essentiel
c'est de sauver des vies humaines chaque
jour avec moins d'armes compte c'est à
dire qu'il faut donner des armes les
plus les arbres arrive rapidement plus
des vies en faisant cela lorsque est
intéressant sur cette question de
l'union européenne ce qu'emmanuel macron
a souhaité que l'union européenne puisse
envoyer un signal clair et positif à la
moldavie la moldavie qui est candidate
justement l'adhésion de l'union
européenne et le président français a
dit qu'il fallait qu'il y ait un signal
clair lors des prochains sommets
européen des 23 et 24 juin prochain on
va l'écouter le président français
s'était lors d'une conférence de presse
avec justement la présidente moldave il
ya quelques instants
enfin qui aura une réponse intermédiaire
ni un statut intermédiaire
il ya une question qui est posée qui est
instruite par la commission européenne
et les membres du conseil auront à se
prononcer
je ne veux pas ici
préjugés de cette décision mon rôle
étant plutôt de bâtir le consensus en
tant que présidence tournante de ce
conseil européen
mais mon souhait est que nous puissions
envoyer un message positif et claire à
cette demande
oksana mitrofanova vous souhaiteriez que
le président de la république française
fasse le même type de geste à l'ukraine
pour une potentielle entrée dans l'union
européenne mais bien sûr du pays l'ong
terme aussi on attend le signal de la
france parce que c'est quand même sur
une piste très importante dans l'union
européenne
et on comprend très bien que la
coopération avec la france est
essentielle et le soutien de la france
et c'est alors du jour est bien sûr
maintenant quand il y en a des
négociations
ou le processus pour donner le statut
des candidats deux candidats le crayon à
l'adhésion à l'union européenne en tant
que la réaction de france et moi par
exemple j'ai déjà entendu leurs propos
du président du sénat de gérard la
recherche qu'ils étaient positives sur
le support et bien sûr maintenant c'est
alors au président de le république de
s'exprimer sur ce que vous attendez
véritablement de l'union européenne
lorsqu'on est ukrainien c'est une
question de valeurs c'est une question
de protection militaire alors qu'il
n'est pas vraiment de défense européenne
qu'est ce que ça représente l'union
européenne 1 d'abord à l'union
européenne bien sûr c'est les valeurs et
puis aussi c'est la liberté c'est la
liberté de choix peut-être vous vous ici
en union européenne vous savez déjà on
peut oublier qu est-ce que c'est la
liberté et avoir la possibilité de faire
le choix et il faut peut-être on peut
rappeler de ça parce que regarder la
russie s'est il ya le régime autoritaire
tandis que pour lequel la bataille se
mène exactement pour la possibilité de
faire le show pour construire l'état
démocratique donc bien sûr on attend
plein de choses de l'union européenne
c'est les futures adhésions mais c'est
qu'il s'agit qu'il n'a pas de l'europe
de défense mais peut-être c'est déjà
possibilité de réfléchir et comprendre
qui est peut-être là mais on craignait
n'est-il pas si on composante importante
de futurs l'armée européenne
réfléchissait alberto toscano est-ce que
effectivement parce que bon il ya 27
pays membres de l'union européenne donc
lorsqu'on est réaliste on sait
d'ailleurs que ça se bouscule au sein de
l'europe centrale et orientale y ait un
certain nombre de pays qui soit déjà
rentrés depuis un certain temps c'est
très long est-ce quel type de promesses
l'union européenne peut-elle faire à
l'ukraine ou encore à la moldavie non
mais bien une chose acquise l'ukraine
doit absolument avoir le statut de
candidat un trait de l'union européenne
ensuite il y alors que l'on sait qu'il
ya la question à l'écran les alors des
liens avec tous les pays candidats qui
sont nombreux y compris malheureusement
la turquie mais mais
vous avez compris que je
ne pense pas que le régime touchait ce
soit spécialement démocratique et dont
le don qu'il faut qu'à ce stade il
discours du président un maquereau a été
d'ailleurs l'interview la presse
régionale qui parlait d'un conteneur de
pays qui seraient susceptibles de se
trouver dans un état de ne pas être
réunion européenne mais d'avoir une
relation privilégiée avec la binette et
politique voilà donc illusion pays dont
des pays de l'ex yougoslavie
de qui sont dans cet état et il faut
créer aussi un compte twitter qui
permettent à le crème d'être plus
intégrée dans l'europe communautaire
dans un sens large du terme déjà
aujourd'hui marie dumoulin justement
cette idée de communauté politique
européenne ce avait d'ailleurs fait
réagir dans le mauvais sens et
ukrainiens qu'ils disaient on n'est
quand même pas des européens de seconde
zone est ce que c'est permettrait tout
de même sens de ce tacle transitoire ou
est ce qu'il faudrait dire tout
simplement à l'ukraine et à la moldavie
en l'occurrence bon vous rentrez vous
allez avoir le statut de pays qui
demandait une adhésion alors le débat
pour le prochain conseil européen ils
portent précisément sur le fait de
donner ou non à l'ukraine et à la
moldavie et à la géorgie d'ailleurs le
statut de candidat donc c'est le début
d'un processus qui ensuite les conduire
et
il finit à l'adhésion ce processus il
est extrêmement long et on le voit avec
les pays des balkans occidentaux il y en
a un certain nombre qui sont déjà
candidats depuis des années et ça
progresse pas très vite et on vous
parlait quoi de l'albanie alors
l'albanie justement n'a pas encore
ouvert de négociations d'adhésion mais
un pays la serbie la serbie le manteau
beige jour le moment janeiro à des
négociations d'adhésion qui sont
extrêmement longues extrêmement
compliqué était extrêmement frustrante
donc pour moi cette idée de communauté
politique c'est une manière de pouvoir
envoyer un signal positif à l'ukraine et
à la moldavie en leur donnant statut de
candidat tout en créant une enceinte qui
permettrait de rapprocher ces deux pays
mais aussi les pas et le pays des
balkans occidentaux de l'union
européenne de les associer peut-être
davantage à la prise de décision est
quelque part de les renforcer aussi dans
la période qui va précéder leur adhésion
qui peut durer assez longtemps qui sera
une période difficile parce qu'il y aura
une toute une série de réformes à faire
pour des pays qui sont fragiles fin dans
le cas de la moldavie c'est le pays plus
pauvre du continent européen c'est un
pays qu'on demande effectivement un
niveau de richesse ondemand payer le
taux d'inflation il ya beaucoup de
critères macroéconomiques pour entrer au
ca y est en tout cas une convergence
économique avec les pays européens qui
est nécessaire aussi pour ne pas
détruire ces pays et ne pas le faire en
sorte qu'ils aient pas une émigration
massive le jour où ils entreraient dans
l'union européenne qui les hydres est
complètement de leur de leurs forces
vives nicolas tenzer mais manifestement
effectivement les ukrainiens ne souhaite
pas je pense qu'il ya plusieurs choses
effectivement je pense que dans le cas
de la moldavie et de l'ukraine la
géorgie est un autre cas pour des
raisons politiques aujourd'hui de fait
je pense que le statut de candidat doit
être clairement accordé lors du conseil
des 23 et 24 juin n'est pas question
d'attendre candidats ukrainien al
candidats l'ont dit d'accord une fois
candidat à aubagne à la gironde il
reparle de candidats que deuxièmement
moi ça m'a frappé au corps crochète et
en ukraine il ya quelques semaines je
veux dire quand on voit ce pays quand on
discute avec les gens de ce pays je vais
en ukraine régulièrement depuis 15 ans
maintenant je veux dire on n'a plus le
même pays on a un pays qui se rapproche
encore une fois en termes de
performances de fonctionnement de l'état
de fonctionnement des collectivités
territoriales des associations de
qualité de l'élite qui se fond qui se
rapproche de plus en plus
les critères européens et je pense que
l'idée je pense que vous ne craignez
sera prête dans sept ans à peu près pas
dans des dissidents dans sept à huit ans
difficile après à vous de voir mais
surya dessus gère bien sûr il ya
toujours le problème de la corruption
qui a un vrai sujet personne ne peut le
cacher mais bon maintenant je pense que
le vrai le vrai enjeu aujourd'hui c'est
de comprendre que ce n'est pas un cadeau
que nous faisons à l'ukraine mais que
c'est un atout pour l'union européenne
c'est vraiment regarder l'économie
regardez en termes de sécurité regardez
la qualité de l'armée l'ukrainienne
regarder les nouvelles technologies
connaissez il ya beaucoup de gens en
france et dans les élites qui ne sont
jamais allés en ukraine où il ya là une
fois ou deux fois jane grey ils ne
connaissent pas le pays et je pense que
ça vraiment voilà je pense que vraiment
un atout pour lui on rappelle à tous
points de vue et ça il faut pas
l'oublier pas uniquement dans le
discours à huy l'assistance on va les
aider et c'est non il faut le voir pour
nous ce que ça nous représente roxana
mitrofanova quelle réaction russe on
peut attendre si jamais effectivement il
ya une adhésion qui est acceptée par
l'union européenne est ce qu on pas
craindre est-ce que vladimir poutine
pourrait pas justement mal réagir et se
dire bon maintenant qu'ils vont entrer
dans l'union européenne ça va être pire
c'est à dire à m est ce que ça vous
intéresse je mens la réaction russe bien
sûr on peut voir quelle heure russie
change sa position de chaque joueur donc
on ne peut pas avoir vraiment des
prévisions d'abord là aussi peut dire
qu'elle est contre l'adhésion de
l'ukraine dans l'otan ensuite les
contrats l'adhésion de rennes dans
l'union européenne
mais après il ya par exemple les propos
d medvedev de l'ancien président de
russie qu'il est à prendre en compte
l'existence de cet état est ce qu'il
faut prendre en compte et je remonte sur
les les demandes des pays autoritaires
et il me semble que l'union européenne
se créent sur le sur le désir de liberté
mais c'est aussi c'est quelque chose
liberté l'envi des pays dé rejoindre
l'union européenne quand il ya les
réformes qui sont menées pas une ligne
rouge justement qui risquerait de faire
en sorte qu'il y ait une sorte de
contagion horizontale du conflit ah non
parce que pour moi déjà c'est ce que
passe maintenant ce panier question de
ni l'otan ni l'union européenne mais il
faut comprendre que cette guerre c'est
la guerre de civilisation tout
simplement il ya la bataille de régimes
autoritaires contre le régime
démocratique ici on conte quand cette
part a dit l'essentiel de ce guet russo
ukrainien on peut voir qu'il ya aussi
c'est la guerre du passé parce que la
rue s'il de reconstruire lempire avec
l'état qui représentent l'avenir c'est
que l'ukraine qui aspirent à voir l'état
démocratique et bientôt toscano est à
l'écouté des régimes démocratiques il ya
la très démocratique turquie il ya la
situation que les turcs profitent de
cette crise
et il ya plein de choses qui sont
oubliés dans cette crise on ne voit une
partie essentielle je suis dire que
essentielle mais on
voit on a du mal à voir la vision
d'ensemble et le besoin absolu d'y bâtir
un système de sécurité plus solides en
europe qui inclut tous rides des
situations et peut-être de sacrifices
donc quel type d'architecturé en fait
vous voyez en europe à cette
architecture est tout d'abord
cessez-le-feu en ukraine et ensuite des
négociations
il y aura des médiateurs par exemple et
israël ces candidats être médiateur je
pense que les israéliennes qui
d'ailleurs ont évité de faire
l'essentiel à la russie que paient de
l'union européenne a fait et les
israéliens pourraient être dans une
situation privilégiée pour gérer une
médiation donc vous feriez vous avez
envoyé le sang une médiation israélienne
comme une médiation turque à vous
écouter le prix de la médiation du conte
le voit les soutenir dans l'écrasement
totale du peuple kurde oui juste oksana
a dit quelque chose de fondamental en
dix ans arrêtons de tenir compte de
monsieur poutine et de ce que pensent de
ce que pourraient penser monsieur
poutine
je veux dire on a on a trop parlé du
rôle là il faut pas il faut pas
provoquer la russie il faut surtout pas
d'escaladé avec la russie qu'est-ce
qu'elle a été le résultat c'était une
guerre et j'ai plus de cent mille morts
je dirais en ukraine et combien ailleurs
aussi je veux dire non il faut il faut
arrêter il faut il faut arrêter de dire
on tient compte parce que
malheureusement nous nous affaiblissons
et nous donnons des armes monsieur
poutine pour poursuivre son offensive de
déstructurer le moulant la position des
diplomates cris que vous êtes en ce
diplomate justement
d'une part il me semble difficile de
donner à un pays tiers un droit de
regard sur les décisions que nous
prenons en tant qu'etat souverain sur
qui on souhaite avoir dans cet ensemble
qu'est l'union européenne est pour moi
la vraie question à se poser c'est
comment est ce que nous on souhaite
définir ce projet politique qu'est
l'union européenne et que recherche en
fait les pays qui sont candidats à
l'adhésion à cet ensemble est ce qu on a
un projet politique partagé ensemble
sexy vous permettez on est tous d'accord
au moins sur une chose le crains doit
avoir le droit d'entrer dans l'union
européenne et la russie ne peut pas
mettre de veto sur ce ce projet
politique qu'est ce qu'il pourrait être
justement que sanaa mitrofanova serait
pas avec l'union européenne d'abord il
faut dire qu'il a annoncé son projet
c'était pas clair donc comme c'était pas
clair du tout c'était mal perçue en
ukraine parce qu'on a vu ça comme
alternative de l'adhésion à l'union
européenne voir on a vu ce qu'on faisait
en son adhésion soit rien du tout c'est
encore ce qu'il ya comme attention ce
qu'ils ont accompli au début ensuite les
propos des ministres clément de bosses
étaient pas rassurant du tout parce
qu'il a dit qu'il faut attendre quand on
voit rarement temps tellement l'addition
locaux mais encore une fois j'insiste il
faut voir une vraie diallo parce que le
situation c'était par marzoug l'est avec
la visite de la ministre des affaires
étrangères française et qui offre parce
que quand madame colonna elle a eu
négociation ne pourparlers avec notre
ministre des affaires étrangères métro
que le bas c'est qu'il a tout de suite
publié dans le réseau qu'il est très
contente des explications est passé et
madame colonna elle dit claire et nette
que ce projet c'est pas du tout ni
alternatif arzate de l'édition l'ukraine
à l'union européenne mais c'est plutôt
un projet grâce au lait qu'ils la france
va aider à l'ukraine 2 2
de passer cette période de
transformation voire assister ici il
s'agit vraiment l'aide de la france
période transitoire bien sûr c'est
quelque chose positive donc cette
confédération politique enfin cette
communauté politique dont a parlé
emmanuel macron les ukrainiens ne
seraient pas défavorables aujourd'hui ça
tellement il ya une canne et sa dépense
parce qu en parallèle il ya cette
situation n'avait que le statut des
candidats de
x peut-être arrêter on peut le langage
diplomatique
il faut parler plus clairement qu'ils
ont dont le statut de candidat à l'union
européenne pour le cren que le crâne a
plein droit l'entrée à l'avenir à
l'union européenne mais sur ce chemin
grâce c'est un projet de comité des
communautés politiques la france va
assister avec d autres pays européens
substitut manquer ce projet je suis
désolé vous reposer cette question parce
qu en fait quelqu'un quel projet vous
souhaitez vous en tant que craignait
n'avoir avec l'union européenne qui est
déjà à 27 a beaucoup de mal parce qu'on
voit la gestion des crises est compliqué
27 pays qui sont déjà très différent
alors l'ukraine est encore plus
différent d'un point de vue économique
que les autres donc elle quel type de
projet vous souhaitez en fait avec
l'union européenne en voyant que c'est
compliqué tout de même comme communion
d'accord bon bien sûr il ya beaucoup de
facteurs beaucoup d'animation n'a pas de
temps par les deux tours mais moi je
voudrais juste un facteur moi je connais
très bien la politique française et
c'est exactement c'est la france qui
depuis des années
ainsi sur l'autonomie européen d'ici
dans le domaine de sécurité de la
défense le problème c'est exactement
créé l'armée européenne a retardé leur
mère craignant l'armée craignant meta
c'est la seule armée au monde qui est
capable mener la guerre avec la russie
c'est la seule arme qui maîtrise et
larmes soviétique et maintenant on
apprend vraiment très très vite la rue
des pipots tania est aussi la leur
strictement craignant qu'on missile ni
tourner comme l'art vous voulez vous
parle effectivement dans l'intérêt
militaire donc une alliance militaire
pourquoi pas marie dumoulin ça irait
dont j'ignore le projet d' emmanuel
macron créer une défense européenne
d'intégrer finalement l'ukraine parce
qu'elle a
vu la force de son armée je pense pas
que ça puisse se réduire à cette
dimension là et je pense qu'il ya de
vraies questions qu'il faudra poser dans
les années qui viennent sur les
procédures de décisions sur le
fonctionnement interne de l'union
européenne aussi et pour échanger
directement à l'issue de cette si on
s'était intégré
entre six et huit pays dans les dix à
vingt ans qui viennent il faudra à un
moment se poser la question de comment
on prend des décisions comme on fait
pour intégrer un pays de 40 millions
d'habitants c'est à dire enfin c'est à
dire un grand pays pour les paramètres
européen
pour que les institutions européennes
constituent continue à fonctionner donc
il ya vraiment toute une série de
dimension à prendre en compte
effectivement la dimension sécuritaire
est importante mais il faudrait
certainement pas que la discussion se
réduisent à ça
je me souviens 7 décembre 91 à
maastricht le président mitterrand a
fait une conférence de presse à 3 heures
du matin et il a dit on aura une monnaie
unique et à terme une politique
étrangère et de la seule défense commune
on a vu la monnaie unique on n'a pas vu
la politique étrangère et de la défense
mais la france et l'italie et
l'allemagne ont toujours parlé ensemble
de ces deux éléments pour le secteur
comment de la défense mais aussi
politique étrangère commune donc ce
n'est pas seulement question militaire
c'est une question d'intégration
beaucoup plus profonde qui inclut la
politique étrangère commune et une
politique commune aussi de la production
de
huy d'abord pour appeler premièrement
qu'il faut jamais oublier maidan quand
même c'est une révolution au nom des
valeurs européennes que deuxièmement
encore une fois moi je ne vois pas qu'il
faille considérer l'ukraine comme un
pays au rabais parce que je veux dire si
on regarde d'autres pays de l'union
européenne l'ukraine et quand même
beaucoup plus fort et troisièmement que
le cas de l'ukraine de la moldavie en
termes de fiabilité y compris
géostratégique c'est pas le même cas que
la serbie ou la géorgie aujourd'hui il
faut pas l'oublier non plus merci
beaucoup nicolas tenzer merci alberto
toscano merci beaucoup marie dumoulin
merci à vous oksana mitrofanova d'avoir
été avec nous merci à vous tous deux
d'avoir suivi vous pouvez retrouvez
l'émission du débat en podcast également
écrit sur les réseaux sociaux et sur le
site internet
www.francebillet.com rester
[Musique]